Você tá tomando iodo errado e isso pode
estar piorando a sua tireoide sem você
saber. Um em cada quatro pacientes que
toma doses altas de iodo piora
significativamente. A tireoide
destruída, você sente aquele pique de
energia inicial, acha que tá melhorando,
mas é o tecido sendo atacado. Depois vem
o creche, TSH dispara, anticorpos sobem
e você acelerou a progressão da doença.
Isso não sou eu dizendo, é a pesquisa da
Dra. Isabela Went com centenas de
pacientes e tem mais 50% dos suplementos
de Kelp testados conham duas vezes o
iodo declarado no rótulo. Um estava
contaminado com arsênio. E você tá
tomando todo dia, achando que tá se
cuidando. E pessoal, eu tenho uma
confissão a fazer. Sabe aquele momento
que você descobre que você tava fazendo
não era o melhor, mesmo tendo as
melhores intenções? Pois é, durante anos
eu prescrevi do Kelp para pacientes com
doença de rashimoto, problemas de
próstata e de mama, achando que eu tava
arrasando por ser um produto natural
extraído a partir de um alimento com
alta concentração de nutrientes. Até que
um dia, revisando a literatura mais
recente, tomei um susto daqueles. E esse
vídeo é sobre isso. Então fica até o
final para você entender o que que os
meus estudos me revelaram e o que que
eles mudaram na minha prática médica. E
sim, antes que alguém fale, coloquea
aqui nos comentários, o Dr. Lair fala
isso há muitos anos. Eu fiz a posse, Dr.
Lair. Eu conheço esse assunto há pelo
menos 8 anos, só que eu não gostava de
usar o Lugol na maioria dos pacientes
por causa dos dados da Dra. Isabela
entes, que eu já vou apresentar um pouco
mais à frente nesse vídeo. Segura as
pontas aí que eu já vou falar disso. Se
você tá tomando kelp, espirulina ou
clorela para suprir o iodo, precisa
acompanhar os argumentos desse vídeo,
porque o que eu vou te mostrar pode
mudar completamente sua saúde tirodiana,
sua energia e se você é mulher, sua
proteção contra problemas mamários e
ovarianos.
Vamos começar do básico porque muita
gente confunde tudo. Kelp é uma alga
marinha e espirulina é uma canobactéria
de água doce. Clorela é outra microalga
de água doce. São coisas completamente
diferentes. E quando o assunto é iodo,
essa diferença é gigantesca. Espirulina
tem entre 0,5
e 1,5
microg iodo por gama. Você precisaria
engolir 100 g por dia para atingir a
necessidade básica de 150 microg. 100 g,
cara, é impraticável. E clorela, mesma
história, são excelentes para outras
coisas, para outras coisas, proteínas,
antioxidantes, clorofila, detox, mais
para iodo, esquece. Seu médico
prescreveu espirulina ou clorela
pensando que você vai suprir suas
necessidades de iodo, vocês dois
precisam ter uma conversa. Agora vamos
pro kelp, que é onde a coisa realmente
complica. Kelp é alga marinha do oceano
e sim contém iodo. Mas quanto? Aí que tá
o problema. Estudos europeus recentes de
2023 da Agência Europeia de Segurança
Alimentar analisaram algas marinhas
comerciais e encontraram uma variação de
iodo em Kelp de 5 a 5600 mg por g. Isso
é uma variação de mais de 1000 vezes.
1000 vezes. Como é que você vai
prescrever dose precisa com essa
variabilidade? E tem mais, Kelp absorve
tudo do oceano, tudo mesmo. Estudos
mostram contaminação por cádio, chumbo,
arsênio e mercúrio em níveis que podem
ser preocupantes. Um estudo de 2024
testou suplementos de kelp orgânico nos
Estados Unidos e encontrou níveis de
arsênio e cdum que ultrapassavam os
limites de segurança. Orgânico, hein?
certificado e tudo. O Consumer Lab, que
é uma organização independente
americana, testou seis suplementos de
Kelp 2017. Resultado, 50% con duas vezes
o Iodo declarado no rótulo. Um tinha
entre 530 e 960 microg quando deveria
ter 225 e um estava contaminado com o
arsênio. Como esses dados de
variabilidade de concentração e de
contaminação vem de suplementos vendidos
pela internet, veja bem, tudo que eu
falei agora, até agora é de vendidos
pela internet. Então eu resolvi pedir
uma análise técnica a uma farmacêutica
em que eu confio muito de uma farmácia
com excelente reputação. Então ela me
enviou o laudo químico do fornecedor.
Até aí tudo certo. O documento garante
que o teor deodo é igual ou superior a
1%. As boas famáas magistrais ou de
manipulação, diante disso, aplica o
chamado fator de correção, justamente
para garantir que o paciente receba
sempre a quantidade exata de úo
prescrita na receita. Mas o ponto que
não ficou claro para mim e que o
fornecedor também não esclareceu foi a
variabilidade dessa concentração. A
Agência Europeia de Segurança Alimentar
já mostrou que isso pode variar bastante
igual ou acima de 1% pode significar 1,5
2 ou até 5%. Além disso, tem a questão
de contaminação para metais pesados, que
eu já comentei. O fornecedor afirma que
há menos de 10 partes por milhão no
total. um número baixo, é verdade, e
seguro, segundo o regulamento da União
Europeia, mas que ainda assim existe.
Somando esse dois fatores, variação de
concentração e presença, mesmo que
mínima de metais pesados, eu cheguei à
conclusão de que isso não é bom o
suficiente. Isso muda minha conduta. A
partir de agora, eu vou abandonar a
prescrição do iodo kelp e substituir
pelo iodo mais iodeto. Mas calma, fica
comigo até o final.
O que que eu vou te mostrar não é o
lugol como você tá imaginando. Mas calma
também, não é para entrar em pânico em
relação ao kelp. O kelp como alimento em
sushi, salada, consumo esporádico,
tranquilinho. O problema é quando você
transforma isso num suplemento diário de
dose fixa, porque aí você tá apostando
na sorte. Aquele lote pode ter pouco
iodo e você não atinge a dose. Ou pode
até ter muito e você ultrapassa. Ou pode
ter contaminação por metais pesados que
você nem tá medindo. E é aqui que vem
uma questão técnica que poucos médicos
dominam. Kelp contém principalmente
iodeto e a biodisponibilidade do iodo do
Kelp é cerca de 50% comparado ao iodeto
de potássio puro. Ou seja, quando você
toma kelp 500 mg, seu corpo absorve na
melhor das hipóteses, 250 mg, metade. E
essa absorção varia enormemente entre
pessoas, dependendo do estado
intestinal, de outras substâncias
presentes, da forma química específica
do iodo, daquele lote. Bem, agora vamos
falar da ciência que realmente importa.
Existem duas formas químicas de iodo que
o corpo usa de forma completamente
diferente. O iodeto, que é a forma I, é
o que a tireoide capta através de um
transportador específico chamado NIS.
Essa forma é essencial paraa produção de
T3 e T4. Já o iodo molecular, o I2 é a
forma que mama, próstata, ovários captam
por difusão facilitada sem precisar
desse transportador. E aqui tá o pulo do
gato. Estudo de 2005 a 2019 mostraram
que iodo molecular tem efeito
antiproliferativo em tecido mamário que
o iodeto não tem. Um estudo do Garcia
Solid de 2005 induziu câncer de mama em
ratos. No grupo que recebeu iodeto, zero
efeito na formação de tumores. Já o
grupo que recebeu iodo molecular
bloqueou 70% dos tumores. E tem mais,
estudo clínico randomizado de 2019
publicado no periódico Nutrients,
mostrou que mulheres com câncer de mama
que receberam iodo molecular 5 mg por
dia junto com quimioterapia tiveram
resposta patológica completa de 36%
contra 18% do grupo só com quimioterapia
36%
e a sobrevida livre de doença em 5 anos
foi significativamente maior. Então,
quando você toma kelpe, que contém
principalmente iodeto, você tá dando pro
corpo apenas uma das formas, a forma que
a tirióide precisa, sim, mas não é a
forma que os tecidos extratirois
ou extratiroidianos, como mama, próstata
e ovários preferem. É meu caminho
andado, mas não é o caminho completo. E
o lugol? Lugol é solução de iodo
molecular 5%, mas iodeto de potássio
10%. foi criado em 1829 e tem proporção
de uma parte de iodo molecular para duas
diodeto. É brilhante para doses
terapêuticas altas, tipo 5 a 12 mg5 por
dia, mas pra suplementação básica de 150
a 500 mg, aí fica impraticável. Uma gota
de logol 5% tem 6,25
mg. Você precisaria diluir e tentar
medir frações de gota. Aí vira uma
loteria também. E aqui vai o alerta que
eu dei no começo sobre doses altas de
iodo, mesmo quando você usa o lugol com
as duas formas. E foi isso que me fez
usar o Yodo Kelp em microgramas por um
bom tempo. A Dra. Isabela Wends,
farmacêutica especialista em tireod, fez
pesquisa com paciente com Rashimoto
usando doses altas de iodo. E o
resultado, cerca de 25% dos pacientes
melhoraram, mas os outros 25% pioraram
significativamente.
Um em cada quatro, então teve pior. É um
número bem expressivo. E ela explica o
mecanismo. Doses altas podem causar
destruição inicial da tireoideode,
liberando hormônio na circulação.
A pessoa sente aquele pique de energia
no começo, acha que tá melhorando, mas
na verdade é o tecido tirodiano sendo
destruído. Depois vem o creche e a
pessoa fica pior do que antes. Tsh
dispara, anticorpos sobem e você
acelerou a progressão da doença. Então
não é simplesmente quanto mais viodo
melhor. Dose importa, individualização
mais ainda. E nem todo mundo tolera
doses altas, mesmo quando há deficiência
comprovada. Por isso, eu uso doses altas
só em casos bem específicos, com
monitoramento rigoroso e sempre com
cofatores como selênium para proteger a
tireoide. Então, qual é a solução?
Depois de revisar toda essa literatura,
testar diferentes abordagens e
acompanhar resultados clínicos, mudei
completamente o meu protocolo. Hoje eu
uso o que eu chamo de iodo complexo,
manipulação com doses precisas das duas
formas. Por exemplo, cápsula com 165
microg de iodo molecular e 335 mg de
iodeto de potássio. Total, 500 mg, mas
você tem as duas formas cobrindo todas
as necessidades.
precisa sem depender de variabilidade
alga, biodisponibilidade acima de 90%,
síntese química pura, zero risco de
metais pesados, padronização clara e
cada cápsula é idêntica anterior. Deixa
mostrar a diferença na prática. Com Kelp
500 microg você tem dose real absorvida
de talvez 250 mg. Forma principalmente
iodeto, variabilidade lote que pode
chegar a 500%. Isso na compra pela
internet, né? Na manipulação não tá tão
claro. Contaminantes não testados e
proteção mamária mínima porque não tem
iodo molecular. Já com iodo complexo 500
mg, você tem dose real absorvida de 450
microg. As duas formas, cobrindo
tireoide e tecidos extratiro
variabilidade zero porque é síntese
química, contaminantes zero e proteção
mamária máxima porque o iodo molecular
tá presente. Agora, em casos de
deficiência severa comprovada, com
exames na mão, mostrando necessidade de
doses mais altas, aí sim eu uso lugol,
porque lugol tem as duas formas:
proporção validada cientificamente, dose
ajustável em gotas, custo baixíssimo e
mamografia estabelecida há quase 200
anos, mas sempre com cofatores
obrigatórios, tipo selênio, magnésio,
vitamina C e sempre com monitoramento
rigoroso de TSH, T3. 3, T4 e anticorpos
antiperoxidades.
Porque se você tem predisposição
autoimune e não sabe, dose alta pode
virar gatilho e eu não aposto na sorte
com os meus pacientes. Olha, Kelp não é
veneno, não vou demonizar água marinha.
Como alimento em sushi, saladas, consumo
ocasional, top, ótima fonte de minerais.
O problema é transformar isso em
suplemento terapêutico, dose fixa. É
como tentar ajustar dose de remédio
usando chá de planta. Pode até
funcionar, mas você não tem um controle
preciso. E quando falamos de abordagem
funcional integrativa, precisão é muito
importante. E tem outro fator. Quando
você prescreve Kelp, você tá confiando
que a farmácia de manipulação ou
magistral ou mesmo fabricante testou o
teor diodo daquele lote específico.
Testou contaminação por metais pesados,
validou matériapra. Na prática, a
maioria não faz. confiam no certificado
do fornecedor. E o certificado do
fornecedor diz o quê? Teorodo 0,1
a 0,5%.
Variação de cinco vezes na
matéria-prima,
supostamente padronizada. Como é que
você vai garantir dose precisa com
variação de cinco vezes na dosagem? Com
síntese química de odeto de potássio e
iodo molecular, você tem monografia USP,
que é o padrão de qualidade farmacêutico
americano. Controle de qualidade
estabelecido, cada lote testado,
rastreabilidade completa, é previsível,
é reprodutível. Em medicina,
previsibilidade é segurança. Deixa ser
bem claro, isso não é sobrenatural verso
sintético,
isso é sobre eficácia e segurança.
Morfina natural, vem da papola, certo?
Mas você não mastiga a papola para
controlar dor pós-operatória. Você usa
morfina purificada em dose precisa.
Insulina é natural, vem do pâncreas. Mas
diabéticos não comem pâncreas, usam
insulina recombinante em dose precisa.
Iodo, é a mesma lógica. Kelp é ótimo com
alimento, mas como suplemento
terapêutico, iodo de síntese química é
superior em todos os aspectos
mensuráveis. E aqui vai uma informação
que muita gente não sabe. A visão
integrativa moderna não é sobrenatural a
qualquer custo, é sobre evidência
científica sólida, é sobre usar o que
funciona melhor para aquele paciente
específico. Durante anos eu usei kelp
porque parecia escolha lógica, natural,
barato, disponível. Mas quando você
coloca na balança biodisponibilidade,
controle de qualidade, segurança,
reprodutibilidade clínica e eficácia,
baseado nas duas formas de odo, os dados
apontam para outra direção e dados
superam tradição. Então, resumindo,
porque sei que você quer a resposta
direta. Espirulina e colorarela não
contam como fonte de odo. Esqueça, tem
outras aplicações muito boas. Kelp como
alimento é ótimo, como suplemento é
problemático pela variabilidade e risco
de contaminação. Lugol é excelente para
doses altas terapêuticas acima de 5 mg
quando bem indicado e monitorado, mas
impraticável para doses baixas de
manutenção. E atenção, mesmo em doses
altas, cerca de 25% dos pacientes podem
piorar, especialmente se tiverem
componente autoimune não diagnosticado.
A melhor opção pra suplementação básica
de 150 a 500 microg iodo complexo
manipulado com as duas formas iodo
molecular e iodeto. Dose precisa
biodisponibilidade alta sem
contaminação, reprodutivo e você
minimiza risco de efeitos adversos.
E se você tem exames mostrando
deficiência, se tem sintomas de
hipotiroidismo, se é mulher preocupada
com sal de mamária, ovariana, você
precisa das duas formas de iodo. Não
adianta tomar só iodeto achando que tá
resolvido. Tecidos extrairoidianos
prefereem iodo molecular. E não adianta
tomar kelp achando que porque é natural
é melhor. Viabilidade, contaminação são
problemas reais que o estudos documentam
claramente. A ciência tá aí, as
evidências estão publicadas. Garcia
Soles 2005, EFSA 2023, Consumer Lab
2017, estudos clínicos em nutrients
2019, dados da Isabela Wends sobre
reações adversas. Não é opinião, é dado
e baseado nesses dados. Mudei minha
conduta. Simples assim.
Se você tá tomando KP agora, não precisa
sair correndo e entrar em desespero. Não
é veneno. Mas na próxima renovação,
conversa com seu médico sobre as opções.
Se seu médico não conhece a diferença
entre iodolecular e iodeto ou não sabe
dos problemas de variabilidade e
contaminação do kelp, mostra os estudos
ou comenta com ele de maneira
respeitosa. Leva informação porque no
final das contas quem decide é você. Mas
decisão informada é sempre melhor que
decisão baseada em achismo ou tradição.
E se você é médico e ainda prescreve
Kelp, não é sobre estar errado ou certo,
é sobre ter acesso à informação
atualizada. Os estudos sobre iodo
molecular versus iodeto em tecido
mamário são relativamente recentes. Os
dados sobre variabilidade contaminação
de Kelp também. Ninguém nasce sabendo.
Eu também prescrevi Kelp durante anos,
revisei literatura e mudei. Qual é o
problema? Medicina é processo de
atualização constante. O que era prática
padrão há 5 anos pode não ser a melhor
opção hoje. E tá tudo bem evoluir quando
surgem evidências melhores.
Saia do vídeo agora. Se você gosta de
ficar no superficial, eu vou te contar
uma verdade inconveniente. O YouTube e o
Conselho Federal de Medicina me limitam
a que eu preciso simplificar, censurar
dosagens e omitir protocolos
controversos. Na comunidade fechada não
existe filtro. Compartilho exatos
protocolos que eu uso na minha clínica,
casos de reversão que pareciam
impossíveis, combinações of label que
funcionam, fornecedores confiáveis,
interpretação avançada de exames. É
basicamente ter acesso ao meu cérebro
médico sem intermediários. Live semanais
respondendo perguntas, PDF com 47
protocolos exclusivos, grupo no
WhatsApp. Se você quer a visão funcional
real, sem simplificação para as massas,
clique em seja membro. Não é para
curiosos, é para quem quer resultados.